welcome back to the David Pacman show I
am fair and cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David today and if you
want even more from me you can subscribe
to my YouTube channels youtube.com the
ring of fire and youtube.com fair and
balanced and I also host the ring of
fire podcast every week you can catch
that on rofpodcast.com
Fox News as I'm sure everybody is aware
has a defamation trial coming up and so
far it is not looking good for the right
wing Network late last week it was
announced that they privately settled a
defamation claim brought against them by
Venezuelan businessman uh Majid Khalil
and Khalil had been accused on Lou Dobbs
program by none other than Sydney Powell
herself of running a scheme in Venezuela
he helped allegedly get Hugo Chavez
elected working with those Dominion
voting machines and all that other stuff
and
none of it was true it was in fact a
complete fabrication so Khalil sued for
defamation and last week Fox News
settled
now that lawsuit of course is not
necessarily
as intense as the Dominion voting
systems defamation suit and of course
the other defamation suit filed against
Fox news by smartmatic however some of
the claims with that particular lawsuit
that fox has now settled are also
brought up in Dominion's lawsuit so it's
a big deal especially now Dominion can
go to court and be like look jury
they just settled a lawsuit making the
same claims that we're listing here so
that's kind of them admitting that yeah
it was bad and we'll give you money for
it so I know Fox News wants their legal
problems to go away
but at this stage in the game
if you're gonna settle you probably need
to go ahead and settle all of them
that's not a good look for the network
and in a really
really surprising move last week Fox
News also filed a letter with the court
letting them know that they're going to
be offering up certain hosts to testify
at the trial
those hosts include Laura Ingram Sean
Hannity and Tucker Carlson
the three people whose text messages
have been revealed in the court filings
where they talk about how they know what
they're saying is not true they talk
about firing other people from the
Network's producers hosts for
telling the truth I don't know why
Fox News would say hey you want to talk
to these guys under oath on the stand in
front of a jury go for it that seems
like a really really dumb move
I understand in the criminal justice
system
even in the Civil Justice System which
is what this is
sometimes you want the defendant to take
the stand
because they may be able to offer pieces
of evidence or information that might
otherwise not be known right they have
their first hand accounts they may be
able to convince a jury with their words
that they didn't do whatever it is
they're accused of doing
but in the case of Fox News Hannity
Ingram Carlson and the other hosts that
they have offered up
we have your text messages
we have your emails
there is nothing you can say to justify
that material that is already public
knowledge and that of course will be
brought up in the trial it will be blown
up and shown on big TV screens for the
jury to see
word for word what these people said
all this does and again I'm still
shocked my mind is blown that Fox News
is stupid enough to offer these idiots
up on the stand
all it's going to do is allow the
plaintiff's lawyers to walk up there
point to these statements from somebody
like Tucker Carlson and say tucker what
does this mean you sent this right yes I
sent it did you mean it
well yes I meant it so explain to the
jury what this me that is not going to
end well for Fox like 100 percent
not gonna go their way
and speaking of other things not going
Fox News this way they also recently
tried to prevent Rupert Murdoch from
having to testify at the trial
they argued in front of the judge and
said listen judge Rupert Murdoch he
already sat for hours and hours in the
deposition it's on video that gets shown
during the trial too uh so he doesn't he
doesn't need to come testify plus he's
old traveling is hard for him
and the judge actually ruled against
that saying listen Rupert Murdoch's been
traveling all over the world recently
and now suddenly he's too old to come to
Delaware to testify no I don't buy it
I'm not going to go along with it
also last week with this lawsuit Fox
News went to court and asked the judge
to Bar certain topics from being
discussed at the trial
one of those topics was the capital riot
Fox's lawyer said hey judge we don't
want any discussion during this trial of
the capital Riot no mention of the
capital Riot January 6 basically doesn't
exist
in terms of this trial
oh and also
we want you to ban any mention of the
death threats that Dominion voting
systems employees have received
now to a degree I understand
that the capital Riot really doesn't
have anything to do with the defamation
of Dominion okay those two are not
linked so I get why you should say we
shouldn't talk about it I just also find
it weird that you specifically want to
borrow it makes me think you got
something else up your sleeve but the
death threats against Dominion employees
that's literally relevant to the case
like that that is a lot of what the case
Hedges on is the harassment that these
workers suffered because of your lies
not to mention as Dominion pointed out
in a counter filing
people don't want to come to work for us
because they're afraid they're going to
get killed because of the lies that
you've spread about our Network so yeah
that hurts our business which falls
under the category of a defamation claim
fox is in trouble
fox is in big trouble are they in
financial trouble not really it's going
to hurt them yeah because they're gonna
end up paying out a lot of money
probably not the total 4 billion that
the two lawsuits combined are seeking
but they're going to pay out hundreds of
millions of dollars like I I think that
much is pretty much a given at this
point
but the credibility that the network is
suffering
that's going to be almost impossible to
overcome
and what I mean by that is they're not
going to lose the audience they already
have those people are Fox News viewers
they still believe Fox did nothing wrong
those people aren't going anywhere
what they're gonna have trouble with is
when they're very old audience dies off
there's not an audience coming up behind
to replace them
That's The credibility problem
so in the short term Fox will be fine
couple years down the road however
they're going to be in serious trouble